the SAG after strikes are are finally
over so you can finally talk about this
movie uh I guess I wanted to open things
up for you a little bit here and just
ask you what what is the biggest thing
you wanted to talk about about Blue
Beetle that you finally can say to us um
whoa what's the biggest thing I mean the
biggest thing is that I Gotta Give the
flowers to anad the director like
man this was this was two years of his
life he was there every single day
pre-production every single day of
production every single day of post-
production did the whole press junk it
did everything so like the thing that
I'm so excited is like he he handled it
all and and um you know I'm so excited
to for him to get his flowers but really
it was it was such a blast I I love that
a lot of people are getting to see Blue
Beetle for the first time and meet you
know him for the first time and to get
to you know add a family behind that I
think that's something that is
unexpected and that people haven't
really seen a ton and that was the one
thing that I was excited to kind of get
to chat about yeah for sure the family
Dynamic to me is the thing that really
stands out in this film especially
because that's something we don't see in
a lot of movies nowadays especially
superhero movies uh what was it like
bringing that kind of authenticity to
that dynamic in this film was did you
bring any like your own personal
experiences to the role of ha Rees yeah
I mean I definitely did it's it's one of
those things man where honestly all of
the biggest moments in my life I've
shared with my family my biggest
triumphs my my my bad bad days like
are I'm around my family so it felt
really familiar to have a character
where that was like not where they
didn't have to explain that right where
it was just like yep there's you know
mom's is probably walking in without the
door knocking so like that's just how
this guy lives his life and you know for
those reasons that felt familiar to me
and you know there were so many things
in this script reading it for the first
time that I was like wait a second my
experience is universal like I I grew up
thinking like the food on the table was
just dinner not that it was Mexican food
on the table like like so getting to see
getting to see all of these things that
I love and I enjoyed from my youth and
and the things that I love about my
family in a movie intentionally whether
we have to talk about it and reference
it or not you know was was always the
best thing for me and just the
soundtrack is the thing that I go back
to is like damn they just hit it I I
like it it's it is a fantastic
soundtrack uh you know being a superhero
is a big deal especially in the DC
Universe right how did it feel suiting
up for the first time suiting up was was
crazy I mean I I did most of my fittings
out in La where I'm from and I was only
doing like a geve at a time or an arm at
a time or a helmet at a time so when we
flew out to Atlanta and finally got to
like the screen test day and I put the
whole suit on I was fooled I was
straight up fooled I was like what the
heck I'm a superhero what the heck I was
like I was it was it was really really
exciting um and I just have to it it
helped so much I didn't think that I
would shine in a position where I had to
make it all up in my head I'd never had
to do that before and I didn't think
that I wanted to try that for the first
time on my first movie you know so to
have a suit that I could wear you know
to have you know fights sequences that
weren't all CGI was something that was
really I I was so grateful for yeah
that's awesome I'm excited to see where
you guys go next right because James gun
has come out and said
that he does want to continue working
with you and that this character is
going to continue so where do you want
to take haime next I mean I don't know
if it if we're it's too soon to do the
reach the reach feels like big big big
boss yeah but that was I mean I just
want to see where you know Kaji and
himim relationship goes we spent this
whole movie with Kaji as kind of like AI
Kaji because they're not synced up yet
to see them down the line once they're
you know that was my favorite thing
watching Young Justice was seeing that
Rapport there and seeing like yo they
get along sometimes they don't other
times like sometimes he's feeling the
mode you know yeah so so um that's
really the thing that I'm excited about
but put them next to anybody I'm I'm
here I'm here ready to sink my teeth
into whatever you know they throw my way
and um you know more than anything I
just feel so grateful that they we got
the cosign and and you know in whatever
capacity him men his family come we're
ready for it have you talked to James
gun and Peter saffron yet about any
potential future I haven't chatted with
them since the movie released we chatted
a bit before the movie release but no
not anything you know on on the future
of DC like they have more than enough on
their plate trying to handle like the
start of their of their universe and and
I think once that goes as well as it is
gonna go and and as well as it should
then we'll get to see the next steps
right yeah makes sense to me I can't let
you go though we we running a little bit
long time without talking about Cobra
Kai oh snap Cobra Kai back to the dojo
back to the dojo One Last Time one of my
favorite shows you guys are awesome uh
what does it feel how does it feel to
like close out this specific chapter of
your career I feel so sad bro I like
I'm I I started the show when I was
16 we're going to finish and I'm going
to be 23 and I'm like wait I still have
so much so many years to keep hanging
out with you guys I I had so much fun
you
know Cobra Kai taught me so much of what
I love and know about acting and and on
camera off camera the people the
relationships that I made on that show
are ones that I'll remember for my whole
life so um I'm forever grateful for it
and I know it's damn not going to be the
last time that we meet we're gonna I'm
sure five years down the line we'll do
like Cobra Kai reunion or something
like spin-off I'm waiting I'm waiting
for yeah some I need some spin-off I I
would love in anime I would love an
anime spin-off but hey that'd be sick
that's that's for the that's we'll let
the judges decide do you start filming
Cobra Kai anytime soon do you have a
date yet yes I do I do have a date um
and it's right around the corner so I'm
excited to get back in the ghee we
already did the first episode right
before the writer strike so we're going
to hit the ground running I know it oh
nice uh my final question for you before
we before we go what's do you know
what's next a we know Blue Beetle is is
gonna be a thing that you come back to
but you know what's next for you after
Cobra Kai yeah I mean I'm filming I'm
filming it right now my my first day is
tomorrow I'm sure it'll be I mean
in in the time
coming I'm sure it'll be announced or
whatnot but I'm getting to yeah sink my
teeth into the next thing as we speak
right now sounds awesome thank you so
much for your time Jo it's been awesome
chatting with you I appreciate it bro
thank you so much have a great rest of
your day
okay